in Poland this morning President Biden
meets with leaders of Eastern NATO
allies at the end of his three-day trip
to bolster support for Ukraine the
president delivered an emphatic speech
yesterday telling Russia and the world
that in his words NATO will not be
divided and we will not Tire Ed O'Keefe
is traveling with the president and
joins us from Warsaw Ed good morning
Nate good to see you the president's
ongoing tour comes as the war in Ukraine
hits the one-year Mark and the visit has
pitted him against Russian leader
Vladimir Putin with the two leaders
trading accusations as the whole world
is watching
Ukraine will never be a victory for
Russia never
[Applause]
Capital Tuesday President Biden accused
Vladimir Putin in the Russian military
of committing crimes against humanity in
the conflict they instigated nearly one
year ago
they've targeted civilians with death
and destruction Mr Biden said Putin had
not only failed to rip apart NATO and
Western democracies but strengthened
when President Putin ordered his tanks
to roll in Ukraine he thought
we would roll over
he was wrong it was one of the
president's most elaborate speeches to
date featuring upbeat music
[Music]
spotlights smoke machines and children
giving him hugs
it was a sharp contrast with Putin's
National address delivered to a room
full of loyalists he blamed the West for
fueling the Ukrainian conflict
and announced he's suspending
participation in the last remaining
nuclear arms reduction treaty with the
United States frankly we find it
irresponsible the withdrawal came after
Russia carried out a planned
intercontinental ballistic missile test
Monday the same day as Mr Biden's visit
the key U.S officials tell CBS News but
the test appeared to fail we continue to
monitor Mr Putin's nuclear postures best
weekend we've been doing that since he
invaded a year ago
now today the president is set to meet
with leaders of the Eastern European
countries known as the Bucharest nine
they make up NATO's Eastern flank and
are the ones most vulnerable to a
potential attack by Russia aides said
this week the president wants to not
only express public support for Ukraine
but also for these countries and to
reiterate a key part of the NATO Charter
that an attack on any member nation is
an attack on all
Tony that's what the charter says
that'll keep force in Warsaw this
morning Ed thank you very much